The Joe Rogan Experience well that's why
it's so weird when like this UFO
disclosure thing comes out
this guy
didn't just come out today yes a
whistleblower yeah this uh gentleman uh
David grush and David grush let's let's
find out who he is and what his uh
credentials were but he essentially said
that they are illegally hiding it from
Congress and they are illegally hiding
it from the American people but they
have off-world CL off-world craft in
possession who's the they in that it's
somewhere well it's in the things
they're saying is oh here let's read it
Air Force veteran has made a bombshell
claim that U.S government has recovered
materials that could be proof of UFOs
including an intact craft of non-human
origin but they are keeping it a secret
from the public David Charles grush a
veteran and former member of the
National geospatial Intelligence Agency
and National reconnaissance office has
blown the whistle on this information
speaking with several news outlets about
the crafts these are retrieving
non-human origin technical Vehicles call
it a spacecraft if you will non-human
exotic origin vehicles that have either
landed or crashed Mr grush told news
Nation
Mr grush served as the the senior
technical advisor for the unidentified
aerial phenomenon analysis with top
secret secret compartment and
information clearance according to the
debrief he also served as a senior
intelligence officer in the National
reconnaissance office in total he has 14
years of experience serving serving as
an intelligence officer so here's the
question
is that a psyop
is this uh we've got a non-human craft a
psyop like if I was the government
hahaha
and I was working on some [__] and I
didn't want China or Russia to know
about it and we could do some wild [__]
some anti-gravity [__]
I thought it was totally nuts and I
thought at first I was being deceived
but it was a ruse Mr Rush told news
Nation people started to confide in me
approach me I have plenty of senior
Former Intelligence Officers that came
to me many of which I knew almost my
whole career that confided in me that
they were part of a program he told the
debrief that he's been that he's
prepared many briefs on UFOs for
congress but last year decided to
provide hours of classified information
and data about the materials recovery
program Mr grush claims the materials
recovery program was shielded from
proper congressional oversight
so this is what Bob Lazar has been
saying forever
this guy's saying that it was going on
for 80 years
so like this brings us back to the 1940s
I mean this is like this is means like
Roswell this is what they were talking
about when all the people that were at
Roswell that were at the actual crash
site and the actual claim they saw
bodies and then there was two different
aircrafts that were flown in to Roswell
New Mexico and took the wreckage and
flew it in two different aircrafts in
case one of them crashed supposedly and
they flew into Wright-Patterson Air
Force Base this has all been documented
now that was a balloon it was just a
balloon why would they go through such
lengths and why there's so many people
that have so many stories about Roswell
why there's so many
hokey goofy [__] explanations of what
happened including it was a parachute
and there was there was human dummies
like Crash Test Dummies that were
evolved because they were crash testing
things like
not not according to the people that
were there what they saw was materials
that could not be explained insanely
light you would crumple it and it would
immediately Flex back to the the stage
that was out there and they found things
that had some sort of writing that
resembled hieroglyphs
they don't I mean these people they
could have all been full of [__] it
could have been just some story
something happened and everybody told
everybody and you're playing a game with
telephone and actually you know it's
this wild story of bodies and little
tiny caskets and the you know and people
being silenced and but the problem is
the story is very Universal when they're
all telling a story it's a real similar
man it's a real and the guy who was who
was a part of the initial release he
went public afterwards and said that's
stuff that we we showed the American
public when they were sitting there I
forget the gentleman's name but he was
showing like a piece of a weather
balloon and they had this smile on their
face
this is one day after the I think it was
the Roswell Daily Record they had the
front page of the newspaper the
government has recovered a crashed UFO
I mean I don't know how big the universe
is I've heard it's hard to quantify in
size
yeah that's it right there I mean what
do you think the odds are and all of the
universe that we are alone it's not good
if if it is it's wild if it's just us
it's wow what a weird [__] aberration
not us so for a species I mean we can
look at where we are at we can make it
to kind of the Moon before we start
[__] up
maybe Elon can get us to Mars maybe not
but so let's assume that a species that
was able to come like check us out is
probably more advanced
probably more intelligent
I think they would run for the [__]
kills why because we are idiots
and I think anybody who viewed Humanity
from a long enough more objective lens
would say maybe we can just leave this
trash Planet alone for a little bit and
we'll come back after either they have
killed themselves again and regrown into
something better or when they come and
visit us and he's the guy who's like
he's ended his career to come out and
talk about the stuff because he's like
like this is nuts like this is and if
you're a real Patriot that's probably
the thing you do and and apparently
according to Sagar on uh he was talking
about breaking points the New York Times
rejected this The Washington Post
rejected this they didn't want to talk
about it this is the gentleman so let's
play this to you mate these are
retrieving non-human origin technical
Vehicles you know call it spacecraft if
you will it's probably not the right
parlance but uh no kidding non-human
exotic origin vehicles that have either
landed or crashed we have spacecraft
from another species we do yeah
how many
quite a number
where's the where's the whole interview
um probably that website see if you can
find is that something you have to sign
up for what is it news what is it news
Nation news Nation
meanwhile that might be a 100
government controlled organization that
just promotes propaganda that guy's
working for them you got to think about
all these things I know translation who
are these folks uh
interesting he's their [__]
centerpiece look at that yes he is he
looks a little tanner than usual
can we save ourselves from ourselves Joe
to go back to the humanities sliding
short the brink it's possible oh here's
the 10 minute interview okay let's hear
it how much just play it let's let's
just see what's up military program that
is reportedly found wreckage of fully
intact exclusive
on the UFO question what conclusion did
you come to at the end of your time on
the UAP task force uh the UAP task force
was refused access to a broad crash
retrieval program
when you say crash retrieval what do you
mean
these are retrieving non-human origin
technical Vehicles you know call it
spacecraft if you will non-human exotic
origin vehicles that have either landed
or crashed we have spacecraft from
another species we do yeah
how many
quite a number you're kidding no
I thought it was totally nuts and I
thought at first I was being deceived it
was a ruse people started confiding in
me they approached me I have plenty of
current former senior Intelligence
Officers that came to me many which I
knew almost my whole career that
confided to me they were a part of a
program they named the program I've
never heard of it
and they they told me based on the oral
testimony and they provided me documents
and other other proof
that there was in fact a program that
the UAP task force was not read into
Russia alleges the U.S government
hmm
was it keep going
what else does this say the entire
American public has been lied to for
decades yeah there's a sophisticated
disinformation campaign targeting the
U.S populace which is extremely
unethical and immoral you are saying
to the human race for the first time
an official
intelligence representative at a high
level from the U.S government is saying
publicly
we are not alone we're definitely not
alone absolutely the data points
empirically that we're not alone yeah do
we have bodies do we have species both
well naturally
um when you recover something that's
either landed or crashed
um sometimes you encounter dead pilots
and believe it or not as fan as
Fantastical as that sounds
it's true
it's also harder for people to wrap
their minds around the concept I don't
know man
he might be full of [__] well it might
be I'm fascinated it might be a
government agent well to unpack that a
little bit you know so there are
I can only speak to it from a military
perspective so he was in the Air Force
there are programs
they're covered programs or there are
programs that you're not going to get
read into and just because you're read
into one program doesn't mean you're
going to get read into other ones so his
clearance tssci is not an uncommon one
it's um it's the same clearance that I
held that I was in having a clearance
there's two things right you have to
have the clearance and then you have to
have the need to know
so you could view him saying we were not
read into another program is something
that would be conspiratorial or you
could view it as like one program didn't
necessarily have something to do with
the other one so there's no need to
actually read them in I'm not saying
that's the case
but I'm fascinated to understand it
sounds like what he is saying is that
the United States military is nesting
that program the program to go recover
and I'd be fascinated to know how they
are doing that
invisibly
I mean we're talking aircraft we're
talking identification early on aircraft
moving teams in this you know what I
mean like there's a lot of [__] right
I'm not saying it's impossible I have
but there are people that are coming
forward so it's not like they're totally
being quiet which is sort of they're
coming forward with nature they're
coming forward with a piece of a pie I'd
be fascinated how all the pieces of the
pie fet uh fed together I'm not saying
what he's saying isn't true
but watching that actually for me with
my limited understanding of some of the
stuff he was talking about I have more
questions that I would want to ask him
yeah I would want to ask him too
we got to get them
gotta get them on here I bet he would
come on here let me just kind of go on
[__] I feel like though what the hell
it is I feel like even on a tour it
sounds like yeah oh why didn't he
contact us I think you might get more
circular answers maybe you did
you might get more maybe I asked too
many questions maybe the word you ask
good questions though is he still in I
might not even mad I don't even know if
they probably allow weed in the current
military you might get more circular
answers than specific ones if you if you
look at the answers that he was he was
giving
and again I'm not trying to Discount
what he's saying and I personally like I
have said many times I think it's
improbable that we're alone he was
speaking in generalities and not
specifics he was talking about other
people's experiences less his own yes
that's a good point and that's what my
question would be what have you seen
yeah what have you seen physically with
your own eyes yeah what have you touched
what do you know for a fact
and again I'm not saying he hasn't had
those experiences but I would ask those
same questions as well and it's just
from my understanding of how the
military will compartmentalize as all
organizations who actually want to
Keep information or at least delay the
release of information
compartmentalization is not a novel
concept well that's what Bob Lazar said
was the problem with the back
engineering program he said that science
can't exist like that in a vacuum and
the the propulsion experts were not
allowed to talk to the metallurgists the
Metallurgy experts were not allowed to
talk to the biology experts the the he
said all if they really did have
physical bodies the people that were
working on the propulsion system had no
knowledge of that weren't allowed to
talk about it but they were all there
was all chatter everyone would talk
about things and apparently there was
some sort of a debriefing they gave them
and in that debriefing he said it was so
nuts he said the first of all they said
they would they've been coming here
forever and they also said that we're a
product of accelerated evolution
which is wild as [__] yeah that human
beings in general that why we are so
different from all the other primates I
mean that's always been the [__]
conspiracy theory folklore that's the
fun one you know that they came down
that's the Anunnaki that came down here
and and messed around with lower primate
DNA and did something to it to create a
human being
I'm here for it I'm here for that yeah
that would make everything fun and then
I would think that the government would
want stuff like this to come out if
they're in the middle of like stealing
money or doing something really wild oh
the classic misdirection oh for sure
yeah if you're gonna take something that
gets rid of a certain Amendment are you
going to do something that allows you to
infringe on rights or to impose some new
sort of restrictions and bring the
aliens out yeah bring the aliens out